just to mention that on Monday 10 30 a.m
there's a town hall meeting uh
and also faculty and students of
Berkeley are welcome to attend and now
we continue with Tony a second hour
um and Tony
a question
hi Tony I have a question about your
previous part
you said something about crypto hardness
implies non-automativism ability I can
say that word sorry are there results on
the other direction like if a proof
system is not optimizable you can get a
one-way function from it or anything
like that
not that I know of has anybody else know
anything I don't know I've been
forgetting can you build one of your
functions
sorry I didn't hear what whoever answers
to be an average case hardness
yeah I think it's really yeah
great great question
does anybody else have any um
I I said if you have like an average
case version of automated solution of
instances
then you can try but you don't know
results or you're saying if the result
is true I think something like that
might follow for some artificial proof
systems but maybe not for natural ones
no I wanted the channel for every proof
system if it's not optimizable and some
of them
because for learning we have we have
results like if
in class that's hard to learn you can
build a one-way function out of it right
skl paper it's a good point yeah
thanks
yes
and circuits is not that uh lucid
so I don't think there will be like
something like this specifically uh yeah
yes Tony yeah any other questions
okay so in that case I'll continue and
the next topic is uh lower bounds and
conjectured hard to prove totalities I'm
not going to talk too much about lower
bounds we already have more about
um the struggle to prove lower bounds
for strong proof systems
and that's actually pretty related to
meta mathematics of complexity lower
bounds so yeah these two last topics
will fit in nicely together
okay so just to survey what we know so
far the green line and down is the proof
systems where we have exponential lower
bounds
um and the two aside from ac0 Fraga
which has its own
um story that I'll skip today the rest
of the persistence under the line all of
them can all of the lower bounds can be
proven using feasible interpolation and
there's also another method that's
useful for resolution it was the first
first lower bound that was proven for
resolution kind of used method ones by
Armin Hagen in 85 so even resolution
bounds were open until 85. I know that
seems a long time ago but actually the
question about resolution proof length
was raised in the early 60s so it was
open for a long time even for resolution
and so the first method is quite
combinatorial you first show there's
various ways to do it that you reduce
the size question of a proof like a
resolution proof to a question with so
in other words you show that if you can
prove that any resolution refutation of
some formula has to have at least one
wide Clause meaning you know Clause with
like linear many many literals in it
then you show that that implies that
this that any resolution refutation also
have to has to have exponential size
and so once you have that reduction to
width then the lower bound on width is
an expansion argument so you take
particular families of formulas that are
kind of Highly expanding in the sense of
if you look at the Clause variable graph
it's highly expanding and that sort of
gives you that sort of look if you look
locally at the proof which proofs that
are rule-based like resolution tend to
just are able to just um
you know form their information locally
that locally things will look very
different than they look globally and
that's sort of the intuition for why the
lower bound holds
um but feasible interpolation is really
I would say a more General method that
has been used to prove pretty much all
the lower bounds it can give us all of
the exponential balance below the green
line except for well we'll leave ac0 I'm
not going to talk about Aces or if I get
it for now
um I will say one thing that before we
talk more so there's uh for IPs that's
the ideal proof system
um there's actually a really exciting
line of work I think I got most of them
referenced here that uh and introduced
very very lovely ideas and sometimes
build on often build on known algebraic
circuit
um lower bound techniques that have been
able to establish a variety of really
nice lower bounds but the reason I'm not
covering them here is that almost all of
them are at least the strong ones are
for
um
systems of unsatisfiable polynomial
equations that if you try to convert
them to that they don't really convert
to CNF so the so the lower bound is not
saying not giving too much content or
not saying much about uh the ability of
the proof system to refute unset CNF
formulas so the formulas themselves are
not not this when you try to convert
them to uh to a CNF formula they kind of
become trivial so that's why I'm not
going to mention these although it's a
really really nice
yeah be a whole it would be nice to have
a survey on all of this stuff at some
point um
so back to where we are here
um now again we said that there's sort
of this this uh dichotomy where we have
the simple ones where we kind of have
feasible interpolation and then we have
like the non-simple ones which are above
the green line where we know that we
don't have a standard feasible
interpolation under crypto assumptions
and so we kind of are stuck
um anytime we don't have feasible
interpolation
um and the first the major I mean the
the simplest proof systems yes
um so with the simple ones isn't the
case that in some cases is a degree
bound rather than a size you know yeah I
was so um I think for all of them there
is also size bounce
um
are you thinking of SOS or like you can
usually go from degree to size for these
weak systems
yeah so SOS has a degree size trade-off
just like resolution
yeah it does also no it does not
[Music]
well it depends what you mean by degree
size if if I'm just trying to you know
you don't need to get a great
relationship but if you but if you have
a proof of um small size you can usually
hit it with a restriction or you can
even apply a general trade-off that so
you if you know that the degree is
linear for now so that's assuming
um
yeah I'm not sure why whoever said that
I'm not sure why you're saying that
there is a degree size trade-off for
these it's good enough to get
exponentials
yeah but for all this proof system below
the green line there is a size lower
bound yes
there's an issue with SOS but let's not
get into that it has to do with the
whether you're measuring size by
coefficient by coefficient size or
monomial size and it's known that I mean
there's an issue because it does seem
that there's results that that show that
sometimes you can't the coefficient
sometimes cutting planes is another
system but where there we know that the
coefficients never get big but for SOS
they can grow exponentially big so yeah
so there is an issue about whether we
really have SOS
size ones but we do actually have SOS
size ones for some form is we just don't
we have to pay attention to the
coefficient size
okay and we have a lot of experts in
here but my basic point was a simple one
which is just for the ones below the
line where we mostly have feasible
multiplication we are able to prove
um strong lower bounds and I'll just
mention that there's the feasible
interpolation as craigchek defined it
has been generalized so that it there's
a Suzanne we'll talk a lot more about
this but now we can extract content not
just from interpolent form as a split
type of formulas but if you have an
Arbiters arbitrary C and if there's a
way to talk about computational content
and the proof of an auditory and that's
been very successful and has given us
much stronger ways to connect
um circuit lower bounds to to proof
complexity bounds via lifting in that
stronger notion of interpolation for the
stuff below the green line and I think
Suzanne will talk about some of that
but I want to talk about above the green
line
um so so I want to talk about strong
proof systems and I'm going to mostly
just be I'll just think of Friday
systems and extended Fraga but most of
what I say is also true for ac0 with mod
P you know because you're a p frigger
okay so the first question is um
I'm asking about conditional lower
bounds can we show can we prove lower
bounds for say frigate systems modulus
some circuit lower bound and we saw for
weak systems that weak systems Define to
be the ones that have feasible
interpolation we can do this so we can
usually show that from monotone circuit
bounds we get unconditional lower bones
for the proof system and non-manotone
circuit bones will give us you know
non-monotone feasible interpolation will
give us conditional lower bounds for the
proof system assuming the circuit done
so we have this nice really nice
connection to Circuit lower bounds when
we have a weak proof system the question
is what about strong proof systems we
know they don't have feasible
interpolation under crypto assumptions
but is there a different notion of
feasible interpolation or a different
way to extract computational content
from a from a small fragile proof this
is open
um I will say that unfortunately because
we're not time there's a huge body of
beautiful work about extracting
computational content from a feasible
uniform proof so proofs of inbounded
arithmetic
is that the uniform proof systems that
correspond to these circuit uh you know
propositional proof systems and there
there's very nice lovely witnessing
theorems beginning with the work of
boss's thesis from 85 that shows that
statements of a certain type of a type
frolics that exists a y a of X Y that
statements of that type if they're
proved feasibly that you can extract
from them
um you know
a function for finding the Y and that
function is in the corresponding tfnp
class depending on what the proof system
is so just this is just a forward
pointer that for uniform systems we do
have and we do have a very rich body of
work connecting tfnp classes to proofs
of certain types of statements but for
the propositional proof systems we don't
have anything like that and it's not
just because it's uniform versus not
it's really more has to do with the fact
that the
systems of bounded arithmetic are more
expressible they can express things that
you can't express propositionally
foreign
result that we have in the other
direction
um so the the main thing that we proved
about IPS uh was that
super opponential lower bounds for IPs
imply uh algebraic circuits they imply
VP doesn't equal vnp and this is not
actually very hard to prove once you
formulate IPS in the way that I said and
really just because
um
first of all any onset Cena has uh has
sort of a vnp IPS
um certificate as a vnp proof but on the
other hand if you can if you show that
IPS can't prove a particular family of
unset formulas are showing that no
because because of because an IPS proof
is just an algebraic Circuit of poly
size or showing that no algebraic
Circuit of poly size you know that there
is no
um there is no VP algebraic you know
there's an algebraic circuit for it
specifically yes
um
so we have this for IPs IPS as I said
we know that it's a court record proof
system
um and uh we also don't really know how
strong it is in the sense that even if
you're happy to consider like zarmella
Franco set through some very strong
system we we don't know any kind of nice
axiomatizable system can simulate IPS so
it does give a connection a nice
connection between a natural proof
system and applying a circuit a really
important circuit lower bound but it's
not it's not saying anything about the
standard frego style systems and that's
open whether or not there's some whether
or not we can show that uh super
opponent on the lower bounds extended
fragilins implies some circuit lower
balance such as you know P slash
polynomial equal NP or some other
non-trivial circuit bound
um so what about unconditional phrigal
lower bounds
um and uh so one of the things that's
very different about proof complexity
than circuit complexity is it's actually
much harder to come up with hard
examples so for circuit complexity you
know we have tons of for p versus NP we
have tons of problems that people have
studied you know since before any of us
were born and you know these number
theoretic problems sat where we you know
tons of problems that we think that are
conjectured to be hard
um in this in this scenario it actually
took a long time to come up with
conjectured hard formulas for strong
systems like extended Fraga
um
yeah this is a quote by Sasha and one of
his survey articles and I mean one of
the problems is that when you you're
restricted to write something down
that's a propositional formula so
another this basically you know a dnf
formula and uh so what it was so it
seems like what happens is when you
write something down it's dnf or that's
a proposition performance it's either
not true so then then lower bounds are
useless or it's not known to be true or
false so um
yes so again that leaves you a little
bit stuck uh or you know that it's true
but then usually when you know it's true
you have some kind of proof that it's
you know you have a proof that's a
pathology
um and usually that proof is is
formalizable you know efficiently at
least an extended fragor so when you try
to find come up with explicit uh
families of combinatorial principles
that are tautologies uh that that you
think have required big proofs it's it's
I don't you know it's very hard to come
up with them
um and also even non-constructively you
know for circuit lower bounds it's easy
to you know with accounting argument
it's easy to show that there's you know
non-uniform functions that you know
there's way more functions on N
variables than there are polyci circuits
Computing functions on N variables and
here we can't do that anymore so you try
to count tautologies we don't know how
to you know doesn't seem like the number
of tautologies is big enough compared to
the size you know compared to Counting
proof size
um so we don't even have any way to
prove non-constructive bounds
um
if you want to just it's a little bit
easier to construct examples that we
conjecture require super poly-sized
fragor proofs
um or examples that are if you're going
to prove a lower Bound for a proof
system then this principle will be it in
other words there's complete tautologies
for a proof system so that's what the
soundness is so soundness p is going to
be some kind of a propositional formula
it's of the split type it has an A Part
and a b part I mentioned it before and
it's expressing soundness or negation of
soundness because the a part says that
we have a p-refutation of the formula Z
and the B part saying we also have a
satisfying assignment for Z so if this
was true then the proof system would not
be sound so assuming the proof system
sound this soundness formula is
um the way I wrote it the negation of it
is unsatisfiable
um and it's turns out to be complete so
soundness of extended Fraga is sort of
complete in the sense of uh if frega
could and this is something that cook
showed and it was later showed for more
persistence by bus I believe that if you
formulate soundness of extended Fraga if
frega con ifrega systems can prove
soundness of extended frigate with
poly-size proofs then forget equals
extended frigate and it's an if and only
but we know that if there's some uh if
we can separate frigate from extended
Fraga that that this soundness principle
will do that
similar results for like frega versus
you know you can express soundness of
frega and that's kind of complete first
like tc0 frega versus frega so
this is kind of these this soundness
principle is a little bit hard to work
with because it's not very combinatorial
um on the other hand I will mention the
result but that I always really liked by
Jeremy avigad
um
from a while ago and he basically
reformulated soundness of extended Fraga
um just in a very nice way that um it's
it's combinatorial and talking about
like hereditarily finite sets so it's
some kind of a nice
um a nice version of soundness of
extended Freddy that looks more
combinatorial
and I don't think there's been any
follow-up work to his paper that's
fairly old by now okay so we have these
soundness things but um so far they
haven't been too useful
um and then like I said before for for
like Fraga systems we can there are some
examples so for example uh this I think
this one was formulated by uh cook and
solstice
but you can express like for two n by n
matrices A and B if a times B is the
identity Matrix then B times a is the
identity Matrix
um so that's yeah and let's just say
we're in a finite field so you can
express this as a small formula and um
how would you prove this well the normal
way to prove this is you would want to
compute the inverse and you say you
would need the determinant in order to
prove this because you'd wanted to you
know you'd want to take the inverse you
basically multiply the left side by a
minus one and you know the left and the
right side by the inverse of a to
eventually get the right hand side but
to do that you need to be able to
compete the determinants to know that
the inverse exists
um in that we think requires
quasi-polynomial size formulas not
polynomial size formulas and so for that
reason these Matrix identities are
believed to require super polynomial
size trigger proofs but they do have
polysized extended trigger proofs so
this is a concrete candidate for giving
a super polynomial separation between
frigate and extended frag and it's just
one of many examples there's some other
combinatorial principles that were the
only proofs we know of boiled down to
you know being able to compute the
inverse of the determinant and we think
those functions are hard for polycise
formulas
um
okay
and then the third type of hard formulas
is basically a random formulas coming
from a distribution of formulas where we
can prove that most formulas in the
distribution are either tautologies or
onset I'm going to do unset it'll make
it easier for me so you have a
distribution on formulas and you can
prove with a counting argument that most
of the formulas in this just almost all
of them are unset
yeah and so if you take a random one you
expect it to be on set and we have
examples of such distributions where we
think that the that a random format from
the distribution not only should it be
unset with high probability but it
should require a large extended fragrant
proof even with you know with high
probability
so I'm going to describe some of those
um the first one probably all know about
it just random kcnfs above the threshold
so this is one way to pick a
distribution of onset formulas or with
high very high probability almost all of
them are unset so you
hey we're going to pick a random this is
the distribution of K C and A formulas
and we're going to pick sufficiently
many Clauses each each Clause of sine of
width K and we'll pick them all I ID and
the number of Clauses will be chosen to
be above the threshold meaning the
number of Clauses M will be Delta n
where Delta will be chosen to be above
the threshold so what I mean by the
threshold is this
you know red line here shows for for k
equals 3 that above this line if you
pick a random formula with Delta in many
Clauses it's extremely high probability
unsatisfiable and to the left of the red
line we know that with high probability
the formula is satisfiable okay
so this is a you know so this is a
distribution of formulas and by these uh
by these results
um the threshold properties of each one
as we know that they're almost certainly
on set above above the red line
um and these are actually like
um Benchmark formulas and important for
all kinds of different reasons
um structural properties of these
formulas seem to relate to our
understanding in general of sat
algorithms and the proof systems again
they're natural very natural commonly
studied distribution
Benchmark candidates for satisfiability
algorithms and um yeah I'll skip number
three and then in fact feige's
conjecture is the conjecture that
basically is asserting the strong
version of phygous conjecture is
asserting that's that it's hard to
um decide for a formula above the
threshold it's hard to decide whether
it's unset or not
objecture uh most people believe it I
think and um it's it's been used to
prove some inapproximate ability results
that have not that that were not known
to be provable under a standard more
standard assumptions
and so this is one example that's been
well studied and we know
we know exponential lower bounds for
resolution proofs are random formulas
above the threshold and moreover we even
know that when we're way above the
threshold like almost at N squared
Clauses like n to the three halves
clauses each of you know a 3C and a
formula a random one with n to the three
halves Clauses even even with that many
Clauses so we're way up here you know
we're way unsatisfiable
even there we know that resolution
proofs require exponential size
and actually even for random formulas we
even have lower bounds for like cutting
planes now which is a recent result and
um and and for some of the semi-algebra
but most of the semi-algebraic systems
SOS Milestones that's so most of the
stuff below the line
um but the exception of AC zero frago we
not only do we have exponential bounds
for those pre-systems but we know that
random kcnfs are also hard
foreign
okay so another a really nice view is to
consider like uh not just a particular
one but to view uh
sort of said this in the beginning so
view this more generally is a this is a
way to come up with a whole bunch of
different
card distributions and it's called proof
complexity generators and it was defined
independently by these two groups whoops
I'm going to do that by these two groups
of authors maybe about 10 years ago
and the idea is that you have um
uh you you have a function f that's
mapping elements from a domain D to
don't you know to something in this
range R where R is huge compared to D so
think of d as being maybe I don't know
whatever size d is think of r as being
super polynomial or exponential in
relative to the size of d That's much
larger
and then the
the associated uh formulas will be the F
view where V is in so for every V in the
range here we have a Formula F sub V
that's going to state that V is not in
the range of this function X so we want
F to be
efficiently computable so we can express
this efficiently so we have think of f
as being some polytime function and F
sub V states that V is not in the range
of F and since R is huge compared to D
for almost all V's in R it can't be in
the range because this is a you know by
by week by the pigeon principle that
makes sense
so I'll give you some examples to maybe
make it more concrete
oh let me first say that and you know F
doesn't even have to be a function it
can be a mapping that Maps each element
u in the domain to a small you know it
can be just a graph here or the degree
the left degree of all the vertices is
very small
so instead of being a function it Maps
each element in U to a small set subset
of R very small so think of f f is
taking U to let's say A you know a very
small
very small
subset of r and then the heart is again
as long as the size of as long as the
degree here times D is much much less
than R the size of r
than most V's here will be outside of
the range of f and so again the hard
distribution is for every V over here
you state F sub V is a Formula that
states that V is not in the range of f
okay
so random case that fits in this fits in
this framework the left side is all 2 to
the N truth assignments
and I'm going to do k equals three so
the left side is all three then two
times in the right side is all three
cnfs over n variables with
M should not be n like this
let's do
let's just do one plus Epsilon or
something
I know this is like I don't know maybe
100 n Clauses or so I want to be above
the threshold
okay and then accounting argument shows
you know that almost all cnfs Above This
threshold uh
you know won't be satisfiable so this
mapping again will have the property
that the degree here times the size of
the domain is much much less than the
size of the range and the hard
distribution is just you know you pick a
random formula uh so F sub e which
states that something is not in the
range of f is just saying that the CNF
here is not satisfiable
make sense
so I'm just like I'm just explaining how
uh random kcnfs can be viewed in this
more General way
and some other examples is plants at
Clique so uh and so here I want I'm
going to pick a graph so on the right
hand side I'll have like all graphs with
say half half the edges present and half
edges not present and uh and we know for
such graphs that the almost with
extremely high probability the maximum
Peak size roughly log in with height
with a very high probability
so on the left side we'll we'll
associate with the less cell all K
subsets of the vertices where K is like
n to the Epsilon and we're going to
think of a subset is like a planted
Clique and the form the function f will
map
view U here is a particular subset of n
it'll map you to all of the graphs where
uh where the graph contains a clique on
that subset
okay
and then yeah so then F sub V for one of
these V's we'll just say that you know
which always says V is not in the range
of f that'll correspond to saying that
the graph of e has no click of size into
the Epsilon
that makes sense
so and the
another example is where F and this is
pretty uh a pretty General example
um is where the function f is uh you
know we said before we wanted to be
polynomial time but let's think of it as
a Nissan vigorousand generator so it's a
particular pseudorandom generator that
Maps you know a string U to a much
bigger string B it's easy to compute in
the forward Direction and it's hard to
we think it's hard to compute in the
opposite direction and so now the
function f v you know the formula FV
will say that some V is not in the range
of the of the generator
and a conjecture by rasborough and I
think kreichuk also
states that uh any polytime Nissan
visions
for any nice polytime computable Nissan
Richardson generator it's hard on
average for nc1 that it's also hard for
frega and a similar conjecture for
extended forecast that states that any
Nissan generator that's uh computable in
the forward Direction in NP intersect Co
and P that's hard on average for p slash
poly should also be that corresponding F
sub V should be hard for extended
fragrance
does that make sense so these
conjectures sorry shouldn't the F be the
the function itself that is used in a
Nissan Nissan
yes sorry I'm using yeah what I'm what I
mean here is you have a function f
that's easy to compute in the forward
Direction hard on average to compute in
the other direction and the conjecture
let's all do this one down here the
conjecture is that when you take a
random Formula F sub V which states that
some V that V is not in the range of
this Nissan Venus and Generator so
that's a propositional formula that's
usually uh well depending on whether I
want to say it's in let's have the
formula say that V is in the range of
the generator so almost always that's
going to be unset because you know
because the size of the domain and range
are so different and the conjecture is
that for a random F sub V that's going
to be hard for extended for the root
because it's going to require super
polynomial size trigger proofs
extended fragrance right
and I think that these are really our
best examples uh that we have
um and an instance of this thing is
where the Nissan well you can where the
function f is actually the function that
Maps
um
where the domain here
corresponds to all circuits of some
small size say size n to the 10. and the
right hand side corresponds to all
possible 2 to the N Boolean functions in
the mapping Maps the circuit to the
corresponding function that it computes
so this is an example of you can think
of this as an example of a pseudonym
generator
um or a function that you know that Maps
small elements in a small domain to
elements an exponentially bigger range
it's easy to compute in this direction
and we believe it's very hard to compute
in the opposite direction and
the the F sub V what is it stating it's
stating circuit lower balance so it's
stating V is the not in the range of f
in other words it's stating that this
function V here is not computed by any
Circuit of size n to the 10.
okay so when we instantiate F to be
you know a mapping from circuits of
small size to Boolean functions well
this is an instantiation of this general
idea and then the F sub vs are stating
circuit bounds
some of you these are a function that's
on login variables
um sorry
you're thinking of these as functions on
logic variables well
um so like why do you have only two to
the end building functions
oh that's a mistake no
no yes sorry I'm very sorry about that
yeah
yeah so sorry the strings have length uh
the length of the v's there's two to the
n
and the length of the u's on the left is
something more like n to the 10.
um
thank you
and you know expressing this is a little
is a little bit tricky because you have
to say that some so the number of
variables to express this thing
so V is some particular function
um right and the variables involving the
variables of f sub V are the variables
that describe the circuit so there's
like roughly you know polynomial in N
many variables but to express this you
have to and propositionally you have to
say you know that the function V is not
computed by the circuit so you have to
kind of run over all two to the N
assignments and say that you know one of
them makes a mistake so the size of this
propositional Formula F sub V is going
to be
um like on the order of two to the n
that's going to be like it's going to be
big two to the end but the obvious Brute
Force proof is to you know run over all
possible values for the variables so
that would be 2 to the N to the ten in
this case and so that would be super
polynomial in the size of the input
you can already see that this is kind of
connected to Natural proofs because
um in an intuitive sense because how are
you going to avoid a Brute Force search
over all circuits of size into the ten
or intuitively you have to kind of come
up with some property that such circuits
have and rule out that property and that
property should be not too difficult to
express because it's hard to express
you're going to the proof will be big so
it has to be like a simple property
um
okay
and you know just to say why why we
believe that this should be hard well
first of all we think yeah I mean we do
think that um what am I trying to say
here um
let me just like uh
yeah maybe I don't have any
justification for why we think this
should be hard but I will say that
what's interesting is that in a fairly
old paper by razorov he showed that in
contrast to the fact that we think this
is hard all the circuit lower bounds
that we have so far are actually
formalizable in extended Fraga
um I don't know about the current ones
but all the ones at the time
um and in the process of proving this he
actually came up with this nicer proof
of a switching well very nice Nations
and nicer very nice proof of the
switching Lima
um that was you know because in order to
show that the proof was formalized when
extended Friday needed to actually adapt
change the proof and come up with those
and and that new proof was was like very
useful
um so just the formula the exercise of
formalizing the circuit bounds
um as small extended fragrant proofs
first of all it wasn't an exercise it
was difficult to do for some proofs and
also by doing that shed light shed
further light on the circuit lower
bounds themselves
[Music]
um
okay so let me
so already here we're talking about you
know
the circuit lower bounds is a very
natural is a very natural candidate for
hard tautologies for for propositional
proof systems
um
yeah so and I just want to say a little
bit about sort of what do we know and
what are people studying in terms of
trying to understand the proof how hard
it is to prove circuit lower bounds in
you know in say frigate and extended
frigate and so I already said that the
existing ones are we already know that
they're all not hard for extended
triggers so you know the balance for
um the lower bones for parity for ac0
mod 2
um smolensky basically almost all the
lower bounds that we have the monotone
bounds they're all easy and so the
question is you know how how hard is it
to to prove P equal NP or P naught equal
NP feasibly in other words with an
extended frag of proof
um
so I first just want to talk about most
people don't talk about Partners
approving P equal NP
um because most people think that P
doesn't equal NP so then of course you
can't prove P equals MP but let's just
assume for the moment that P did equal
NP and and just think for a minute about
well how hard what you know could we
prove that feasibly and um so cook a
long time ago I don't know exactly how
long ago but for sure in the 70s I'd
kind of come up with this working
hypothesis that uh basically all the
polytime algorithms that we have so far
have feasible correctness proofs so in
other words if you have an algorithm
that solves matching and polynomial time
you have to have a correctness proof
that that algorithm works and that
correctness proof is always
historically has always been polynomial
time uh if if the algorithm runs in
polynomials in other words historically
or the working hypothesis is you don't
ever or just rare instances of any of
algorithms that are feasible where you
have to go way outside of you know where
you need much more expressive power in
the proof system to prove correctness
um so if P were to equal NP but you
couldn't prove it feasibly then it would
mean that the algorithm for sex would
have to be extremely unusual not like
the kind of algorithms we're used to it
would have to be non-constructive or
somehow
just you know quite quite different than
than the albums we're used to
um
so for that reason I think proving that
P equals NP if one could prove that you
can't prove P equals NP efficiently I
think that's super interesting even
though it it doesn't seem to be
um something that people are currently
working on very much but there is quite
a bit more work on trying to show that
it's hard to prove P not equal and P
okay so that's I've been talking about
that already like trying to prove that
it's hard to prove circuit lower bounds
and extended forever and there's a body
of work on this I would say it starts
with razrat rudish who proved you know
came up with this natural proofs
definition it doesn't correspond to a
proof system but you know they prove
this lovely result it you know shows
that if you if you could prove this in a
natural way that that would break uh you
know that would break crypto assumptions
um and the intuition behind that was you
know this combinatorial property that
was relatively easy to express relative
to the truth table length it's a
polynomial and truth table length where
you know you want to where that property
is distinguishing hard functions from
Easy functions we all know that's
closely connected to mcsp and all kinds
of other stuff that we are going to talk
about in this semester so I think to me
this is really like the starting point
for trying to understand whether or not
it's hard to prove P not equal NP
feasibly
um so then there's a a body of work on
trying to prove unconditional lower
bounds
um
for it's actually
unconditional little balance for the
statement that some function in NP does
not have polycline circuits
and that's formalized in the way that we
said before you take some function and
you express that it doesn't have a
polyci circuit uh and there's
some really I mean these are highly
non-trivial papers that show that even
though these proof systems are quite
weak so rasbrov managed to show it for
resolution in this paper and then for a
generalization of resolution where the
lines are disjunctions of um
so instead of being Clauses the lines
are disjunctions of conjunctions of size
logo again so it's still a pretty weak
proof system
um but but he was able to prove that uh
there's no uh that this proof system and
this one they can't prove uh circuit
lower bounds in polynomial size
um and Raza the first one who showed it
for resolution this uh I put it here
because I I put it here because I don't
remember if
um
uh well okay it matters what the
encoding is sometimes you need the
functional verb all of these lower let
me just say one thing pretty much all
these lower bounds most of them they
work by reducing to a very weak version
of the pigeonhole principle which states
that you can't map like G to the N
Things to
um
polynomial and in you know that there's
no one-to-one mapping from T to the N
Things to polynomial and end things
um so that's how these results so in
order to get to prove these results you
actually have to prove that that
extremely weak digital principle is hard
for the given proof system which is why
we're stuck with these very low level
proof systems because when you get a
Little Bit Stronger uh per system then
it can prove the weak pigeonhole
principle but the Workhorse behind all
these is is lower bounds and yeah you're
right this was the first unconditional
resolution for this super weak
pigeonhole principle mapping like
exponentially many things to pull among
really many things
um yeah synchrosborough was uh showed it
first for the uh
anyways so in 98 so that's
so raspo was the first for PC and then
Raz was for uh resolution
yeah I didn't mention that here because
I'm sorry I thought it would be too much
but yeah
um so anyways these results especially
this one is is highly highly non-trivial
um and but the one weakness of so I
think the really yeah I don't understand
this result but one weakness of these
results is they're not saying too much
about circuit lower Bounds at the end of
the day because the way they all work is
you want to say okay there's no
uh polyci circuit for sap so in
particular that means there's no circuit
that's a dnf formula for each term in
the dnf is a corresponds to a total
assignment of the underlying variables
in other words a dnf formula where each
term corresponds to a total assignment
to the variables is really just a list
of all of the assignments where the
function is one okay so if you have a
function on N variables and it then it's
like say one half the time or a good
fraction of the time and zero good
fraction of time then any such dnf of
that form will have to be X you know if
I'm forcing you to just look at these
really simple circuits that just list
all the ones of the function then
obviously the size of that of that dnf
has to be the number of ones of the
function which is exponential if there's
half many ones yeah so that's the lower
amount is actually for those really
simple types of circuits and the
argument is just that you know if you
could the if you did have a small uh dnf
of that form then you would violate the
digital principle
um so again they're really
the proofs are really cool but they're
not in my head they're not saying too
much about why you know why stat is hard
um
and I want to mention another result I
don't remember how old this is I don't
have the year here but there's a really
nice result uh Jan pick who proves like
a
okay what do we call these things then
calculation
what's the name of this agent escalation
escalation thank you is it escalation no
there's another word amplification
harness amplification so he shows that
for for Fraga systems that if you look
at a particular statement which is
pretty natural statement that barely
super polynomial lower bounds but that
statement actually gives superpoline on
the lower bounds
so indicating well first of all it's a
cool result secondly indicating that
it's going to be hard to even prove
something just barely non-trivial
because already that'll give you super
fundamental order bounds
and then there's a bunch of work that I
don't understand very well so if you ask
me any questions I'm going to ask people
to answer but these are papers again by
with Jan and Rahul Santana I don't know
if elon's here but I'll be able to get
asked him too and these results uh
um you know putting them together
because they're kind of similar uh the
first one gives a conditional lower
bounds for this type of statement that
says so instead of expressing P nautical
n peep so instead of expressing circuit
bounds the statement is going to express
uh lower balance for for a propositional
proof system so it's saying random
tautologies are hard for R proofs for R
is a particular proof system
um and what they showed is that this
statement so in other words proving that
our proofs of random form is have to be
big that's hard for any propositional
proof system
and that's a conditional result so it
uses a as a crypto assumption and then
in a later paper they proved an
unconditional result not for
propositional assistance but for PV for
a similar type of statement it's the
statement is actually uh
it's a it's it's it's a better statement
uh but the but the fact that it's the
lower bounds are for PV make it a week
some of weaker result because here the
lower bound held for any proof system
but the statement was sort of
[Music]
um
not as maybe natural there's a statement
down here
and these are the the tools here are
very different than the tools up here
so I think it would be super interesting
to somehow find a way to combine the
ideas here which I don't understand but
maybe we can do that this semester some
will combine these really interesting
ideas with uh with this more this
combinatorial approach
um and then the last result that I
wanted to mention is there's a result by
the Rahul and Edo so I told you before
that we know that IPS lower bounds imply
um VP not equal vnp so we are have this
direction and they proved uh implication
in the other way that v p nautical VMP
kind of implies IPS lower bounds but
there's a caveat because we don't know
the statement that what they show is v p
nautical V and P implies ipis lower
bonds for a particular statement but we
don't know if that statement is actually
um you know a tautology so it's not
totally clear if this is
um
yeah
has me you know is vacuous or not but
there's good reason to believe that the
statement is a pathology
I guess there's good reasons for in both
directions but anyways
um
yeah and this is probably not everything
that's been done but I just wanted to
give you some feel for
you know for what's known
um I uh I I think there's just a whole
lot to do here and there's huge gaps
between these kinds of results that are
for very quite strong proof systems very
strong proof systems uh but but uh but
the statements of what they're proving
either their conditional and this one is
conditional and a statement is a little
bit not natural but they're but they're
you know proving really interesting
proven results for strong proof systems
whereas these are really weak systems
but it's completely unconditional
um yeah so this is my kind of last slide
or second to last maybe I don't remember
but um so I just wanted to show like the
web of connections here since this is
meta complexity how in my head there's
probably even more arrows but how
everything's connected
um I should have put mcsp somewhere in
here
um but anyways I can talk about that
sometime later
um and then I just wanted to mention
there's a lot of good references because
I know this is probably quick especially
if you
um if you're new to proof complexity
there's a book by Yan called proof
complexity oh it's a very good very
comprehensive book there's also some
quite a few surveys I mentioned three
here there's another one by Nate
segrelin that focuses more on Lower
bounds these are maybe more General
um and then there's some surveys on
algebraic proof systems
um yeah and that's about all I have
unless you have questions yeah and next
up will be Susanna and yeah it should be
a really good talk
say yes thank you Antonio we have quite
a lot of time for questions
[Music]
from generators and I mean this is what
I expected but uh the those are more
proof complexity generators because
um nice some foreign
[Music]
because maybe I don't think I know what
the word proof complexity generator
means so maybe you should clarify that
for the audience for every string in the
core domain that if you can't show that
it's not in the range
so if you have a mapping from like n
Bits or M bits or M is for every string
y of length M you can't show that Y is
not in the range
um oh oh I see so you're saying for the
strong proof complexity generators the
the conjecture is that that for everyone
it's hard
you're right because I just care about
whether there is one that's hard
but you're right there is a difference
for a Nissan vickerson I think people
think everyone is hard and you're right
for random ones that's yeah should be
clear that there's some really easy ones
yeah the decision is just interesting to
stop because
yeah interesting so
yeah that's interesting I guess Clique
is also plan a clique I guess anything
besides Nissan vickerson or the certain
well circuit LeBron is a case of that I
guess yeah a good point
foreign
systems can't do like Shannon Counting
okay could you say it one more time I
had trouble hearing sorry
so if the um weak proof systems
that can't show np9 equals P poly mostly
can't show that because of counting
principles can we also say that they
can't even prove Shannon's lower bounds
like the the non-constructive
circuit lower bounds or is there is
there some Gap there
I'm trying to figure out how one would
formulate that uh
we have to formulate that
propositionally
um
yeah
the mapping is what you've showed
I think you've showed some mapping which
is seems quite similar to just counting
no I was saying
I'm just saying small circuits
um
Oliver said that it is basically the
same
way you would naturally State what is
Shannon's proof or whatever it's just
the pigeon principle applied to that
specific generator that takes service to
their true pills from my understanding
what Tony said is we have a lower bound
against equivalent for that specific
it okay so basically you said that uh
you already showed this in one of your
slides that the mapping from circuits
small circuits into the 100 to the the
set of all Boolean functions you said
that it's hard so it's I think that's
more DeMarco has to have
I'm not sure I'm following this because
I'm having trouble hearing but in my
head like you it's easy to formalize
this and keep you know S12 or something
like that and there I think it's
probably true but I don't know how to
make sense out of it propositionally at
the moment but maybe I'm missing
something
is that job with what you think Oliver
okay so there's no other questions so
yeah it was really a fascinating talk
and fascinating questions
[Music]
um I think Tony again
see you in a week or two or two weeks